what do you think about prenups did you
get a prenup no no prenup no I totally
agree if you're a man you want prenups
I'm not a money guy there's other things
that we talked about and we we've
obviously conversed with money's not
important to me everybody's different
you know what I mean and so if you're a
man you want to prenup or you're one way
you want to print up all power to be be
to it um one of the things I mean my
friends had a great conversation about
prenups and I said the reality of it is
the state has rules if your marriage
falls apart so you should have rules
yourself so this is what I I was talking
to Adam about about the marriage marital
agreement people don't realize prenup is
like a prime uh like a
a smaller version of a marriage
agreement because prenup is only when
it's only a few things but there's a lot
more things that you need to have in
your marriage I.E what happens if you
and I pass away in a car accident who do
our who do our kids get raised by it's a
lot of things that you need to be able
to sit down with your partner and talk
about so to me a prenup is just the
beginning you need to have a whole
agreement where you talk about all these
nuanced conversations and topics to be
able to benefit your marriage in the
long run do you think that men
do you think that men or women are more
to blame for the high divorce rate or do
you think do you think it's primarily
men because and here's why okay who is
the leader in society man well actually
no you don't know it's like women make
70 to 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions who's a leader I'm curious to
your people camera put it on our camera
yeah tell the people who's the leader in
society no matter you're right men lead
so she believed women women have a lot
of power in society today but but you
simply who leads men or women man yeah
right yeah if men are the leaders and
your team loses you play volleyball you
played division one sports you know this
thing I play D1 uh stop it if you I wish
if you yeah are the leader of your team
the team loses what should the leader do
whose fault is it then when the
quarterback loses the game his receiver
drops the touchdown what does the
quarterback say when the interview ask
him why did we lose the game he takes
accountability even even if there was
something that other people didn't
contribute to the loss the quarterback
never throws his team under the bus
which is why Ron Riviera the Redskins
head coach everybody got mad at him
because he blamed Carson Wentz for
losing is Carson Wentz playing good heck
no he's playing like garbaggio but the
court the coach cannot go before the
audience and say oh the the reason we're
losing because of him you're the leader
put that on your back are there things
that women have done and feminism has
done to contribute to the breakdown
Society 100 000 but man I thought we
were the leaders I know we were in
charge how did we let this day happen
how do we let it get to this place so me
personally I understand that if you're
going to be the leader you get the final
say and you get the responsibility when
the team loses I actually kind of agree
with that
yeah because because I think women
wanted a certain amount of power and
like men gave it to them like who
developed birth control it was men but I
do think like it's kind of on the women
though too because we asked for it and
so it's like it's like if you're gonna
ask for it then you can't be mad at the
consequences and now but the problem is
now I think now women have more power
than men like that's just my like we
make 70 to 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions and we we make up and they
it's been proven that women decide
elections if you truly believe that the
power I feel like I'm Andrew Tate right
now the power in today's world is being
held in the hands of women you are
deceiving yourself you think the global
Elites are a bunch of women who are
ruining the world this is not the one
this is not Wonder Woman see I haven't
gotten to the elite stage of red pill
yet the elites that's like a that's like
a term I haven't gotten there yet if you
think who's running the world are women
you do not understand the way the world
Works men have men Run the World men
have the power Just because they give
women a little bit of consumer spending
Goods to be able to shop on useless
things on Amazon it's because they give
individuals a right to vote occasionally
this you think the men are not ruining
this world yeah maybe a small no okay
okay a small percentage but women we're
the ones that are bailed out of every
bad decision we make who make who allows
those rules who yeah why do they allow
but then at the same time who elects
those people women decided to think it's
a democracy in the U.S women decide
elections you think this is a democracy
here you think this is a freedom
democracy where the people are choosing
the leaders come on you're too young for
this uh-huh I think women decide
elections we make we're more do you
really believe okay the the the the the
power in the Free World is being decided
they're letting people freely decide the
elections you think if they don't want
somebody in power they're not going to
make sure this person's not going to be
in power my point okay so you you like
you're on the the voter I'm just having
fun okay no no I don't I don't gotta get
because the red pill conspiracy this is
their this is their ready I don't I
don't subscribe to them I know ceiling
elections I didn't say anything that's
what it seemed like I never said
anything about suing elections okay I
never say anything about stealing
elections I'm just communicating certain
ideas and so my point when you asked me
you said who is at fault I cannot say
I'm a man men are the leaders and then
blame it do women have a responsibility
to the destruction Society of course
they do but men are the leaders it stops
with us a man had to make this a law a
man had to say this was okay but the
women elected them I don't know so you
believe that the women are electing the
men and then the men are so so you
believe the women of the master
puppeteers were electing the the
political pundits to do their bidding
I'm telling you right now if you truly
if you really believe that the powers in
Russia the powers in China the powers
all over these World superpowers are
being run because of a woman electing
somebody into office I'm telling you
right now you might need a little bit
more political research well I just
think it's like when women get into
power we Trend towards communism so
I don't I don't know I just think I I
agree with you like I do think men lead
and so I think the power they gave to
women like like they did give it to us
explain North Korea North explain China
didn't you think China gave power to
women you said is it lean into a
communism you said you think China gave
Powers women that's why they're leading
towards communism they
get back to relationship politics let's
stay in relationships so back to the
relationships who is the major person
that's at fault in regards to the
breakdown of the families do women have
a role yes but I call men the leader so
men are primarily responsible do you
think men are more different today or
women are more different today than the
1940s I think I honestly think it's both
and here's why testosterone levels and
men are at all time what well all time
low you know this stuff talking points
right so you know these things so of
course 100 if if men
the the man in in
1944 I always butchered a year who
invaded Normandy are they the same men
today who are who are who are wearing
their blue hair and their pronouns are
him heard and zip and said and are those
the same men that were invaded normally
back in the day there are some weird
male feminists come on man you think
those you need the same ones
I'm like oh yeah the dude's wearing
dresses yeah these are the same guys
that were back in the 1940s no you're
right come on come on what are we
talking about so that's one of my
arguments is like fellas are half women
devolved heck yeah but look at what the
Kevin we ask them to they'll be like but
why did you listen man you are in charge
of women right
don't listen to somebody when they're
telling you to do the wrong thing as a
leader it's like it's like you use an
example that people don't like if I am
the parent and my child told me I want
cotton candy every day for the rest of
my life you're saying you women are
children I told you I'm using the
example and we're going to get we're
going to get the people going we are a
little bit we're having fun here we're
having fun if you have a child and that
child said they want cat and candy for
every single day for the rest of your
life and you are the leader you are in
charge and that then that child says
they wanted what do you do do you just
simply say the child is crying I give
him the cotton candy or do you say I'm
in charge I'm a leader what's best for
you is this you're not getting that
nonsense not foolishness what do you say
I'm curious you're smarter than me
please teach the people you should just
give the kid whatever they want I love
it because exactly I'm just kidding
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible